the next program i would like to talk
about is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases and this is the
application of
biomedical
data analysis to study
outbreaks for example of epidemics like
we saw in this pandemic but also how to
connect it to
genomic detail in the pathogen and an
understanding of how the pathogen enters
the host and what is the response of the
immune system
so again raquel to your question about
being able to access this recording
after this webinar you will receive an
email with the recorded version or you
can go and and look uh pine biotech look
us up on youtube and the recording is
going to be there on our channel
so um in the context of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases we will look at
a few different specific methods right
first of all we will look at sequence
variation and alignment how we can use
alignment to each other to understand
differences of genomic sequences between
themselves or how do we organize them
into groups using evolutionary and
phylogenetic analysis we will also look
at discovery of variance and association
between variants and specific changes
for example at the protein level or at
the population level and then finally
we'll touch on transcriptomic analysis
of host response primarily around
infected uninfected mock infected types
of experiments where we can understand
the host responses at the cellular and
tissue
level
so uh the beginning of the program we'll
start by kind of comparing and
contrasting infectious diseases with
non-infectious diseases we will then
talk about different pathogens bacteria
viruses
parasites and we'll talk about how they
cause disease what is it that we
actually call infectious disease how
does it manifest what are the specific
things that we look at and how can we
analyze those with different types of
molecular uh indicators and so that will
allow us to understand
uh
using again some case studies how
a number of different types of
could be used to characterize disease
and understand disease progression as
well as outcomes
and that will be uh kind of the main
idea of this program is it's multi-omics
data in the context of infectious
diseases
so
the um
uh
i i think uh um the idea here has become
you know infectious diseases have become
one of those examples where these
advanced new technologies like next
generation sequencing have been used
extensively to almost in real time track
the development of an outbreak of an
infectious disease and also characterize
in very great detail how the
the pathogen interacts with the host in
order to
address that problem and create a
diagnostic
create a panel or a simple process that
could identify a very specific strain of
a pathogen that we now know better how
to deal with
also it has been used to identify uh the
types of vaccines for example that we
would like to design or an intervention
like an antiviral or a drug that will
interfere with that process of infection
and so using these kinds of case studies
we're going to take a look at how does
that translate to actually understanding
the methodology what do we do with data
what kinds of data and how do we
actually practically make use of that
data to arrive at such conclusions
so again i talked a little bit about the
different types of methods that we will
cover and importantly it will come with
several different examples project
examples that you can try
cyrus cov2 genomics of course ebola
virus epidemic as well as malaria
infection and again this will be
primarily around genomic and
transcriptomic data
for hana i think parisa here has a
question on how to register in ilab so
if you could please share that with her
so finally i want to talk about a
program that is not specific to a type
of data or a type of an example but it's
more focused on the project that you
would like to complete during this time
and this is applicable to two types of
people so number one researchers whether
you are an undergraduate high school
student or faculty
if your goal is to perform research and
you would like to
find a specific data set
analyze that data and come out with a
poster presentation or a publication
this is what this program is going to be
designed around
and the second example of someone is
maybe someone who would like to
understand the process of research so
one you know what kind of research you'd
like to do you have a goal and you know
how to more or less get there you need
to help with bioinformatics or the
second one you
don't know what research looks like and
you would like to understand how to
perform research but using
bioinformatics because maybe you don't
have access to a wet lab
or maybe you
are just trying to maybe do two things
at the same time
so the research fellowship is really
around the process of
kind of determining what your research
question is
finding a data set that can help you
address your research question and then
being able to
address
you know the kind of
question that you have with the evidence
identified in a particular data set
and the enablement that we offer here is
big data analysis infrastructure so we
will support your big data analysis
needs if you need to analyze the data
set with 10 000 samples and you don't
you know you can't do that on your
computer you will be able to do it here
mentorship so someone will work with you
to identify a question refine that
question make sure that that question um
could be answered with the data that
you've selected and then
help you get there
and along the way we'll provide you with
opportunities to train yourself to be
able to do this independently so instead
of this being training first training is
embedded into that process because
ultimately if you don't know how to
perform a particular type of analysis
you can just ask someone to do it for
you or here you will learn how to do it
on your own and be able to apply it to
that project
and we've selected a
number of directions on how you can
actually do this in the context of
precision medicine population health
biotechnology and agriculture or space
and astrobiology
so the first step here is going to start
with an overview of the general
background
how to do literature review identify
different things that people have
already done to select something that is
still unanswered or maybe there's a gap
in research or maybe a debate and
controversy and how to use that process
of literature review to be able to
identify a very specific question that
you would like to focus on
once we do that then we have a very
well-defined process that will include
weekly meetings
submitting a form about your progress
keeping a journal of your
progress from learning to identifying a
research project to then conducting the
analysis
and eventually
working with the community of both
mentors and other participants to go
through that whole process and submit
the project and the project will first
of all be submitted on the portal so on
the portal
after you complete your profile
and uh you you know that is free you can
just complete your profile
and update it
you will then be able to uh
start working on a project after you
have 10 000 points and so that's where
the training comes in so you still in
the context of this program will have to
go through some training and importantly
we have another project that is designed
to guide you through the different steps
of literature review identifying data
sets on public repositories like ncbi
and then working through your analysis
once you have done that you will be able
to fill in sections of a project from
title to abstract to methodology etc and
along the way get guidance from our
mentors that will help refine and kind
of accelerate that process for you and
we have a number of uh individuals that
have completed the research fellowship
they have either submitted a pre-print
in the con in the course of the three
months of that program
some of them have went on to then
publish so again i've been talking about
undergraduate students here or even have
used their um results in an ongoing
research study that they're involved in
or just generally use this